welcome to the news hour the governor of
Odessa region in Ukraine says a Russian
drone attack has caused widespread
damage to agricultural buildings the
latest strike preceded planned talks
between the Russian and Turkish
presidents to revive the Black Sea
export deal for Ukrainian grain the two
leaders are also set to meet shortly in
the Russian city of Sochi now we have
reporters in Russia and Ukraine on this
story in a moment we'll talk to dorsa
jabaris in Sochi but first let's cross
over to Rob McBride in the Ukrainian
Capital Kiev and Rob let's just begin
with these strikes in and around Odessa
just hours before these talks and a
timely reminder of what can happen
yeah it would not seem to be a
coincidence at least that's how it's
been viewed here from Ukraine that this
is a timely timely reminder by Russia
just of the vulnerability of Ukraine's
grain exporting infrastructure yet again
this Southern uh region of the uh Odessa
Odessa oblast being targeted it's these
uh Port facilities that go out to her
from Southern Ukraine into the rivers
and Canal systems that feed into the
danuba river which again have been
targeted overnight according to the
ukrainians these waves of drones came
over us something like a three-hour
period uh the ukrainians say that they
managed to intercept and shoot down
about 23 of these drones which again
were said to have been these
iranian-made Shah head uh drones but
there was damage to a number of
warehouses and grain handling facilities
a number of fires were caused a Ukraine
of course has been using these
alternative facilities such as these
River ports and also land Crossings into
Europe as a way of trying to compensate
for the cancellation of the Black Sea
grain deal but also Ukraine has been
looking at ways of trying to establish
its own safe Corridor to guarantee ships
moving out of its main Port of Odessa on
the Black Sea Coast and in fact over the
weekend we have seen two more ships
passing through this Corridor organized
by the ukrainians and arriving in
Romania and Bulgaria and not necessarily
with the permission of the Russians the
Russians haven't had any involvement in
this and that would make four ships now
in total that have managed to use this
route safely out of Odessa since the
cancellation of the Black Sea deal uh in
July so it would seem as though Ukraine
is going about finding alternative
routes whatever is decided in Sochi of
course uh Rob will be speaking to you in
a little while so don't go away Let's
cross over to dorsa Jabari is live for
us in Sochi and Military movements to
one side for the moment uh dorsa because
movement on that grain deal will be high
on the agenda but will Russia resume the
agreement is really the question that
everyone wants an answer to and only
President Putin can give
foreign ly and I think that will be the
top priority for the Turkish president
uh who is who's just landed in Sochi and
he's due to meet the Russian president
in his Summer Palace here now president
erdogan has his work cut out for him
certainly the Russian President Vladimir
Putin is asking for the guarantees that
they sought in the Black Sea grain
initiative brokered by the United
Nations between turkey and Russia at
July of last year the Russian president
is saying that their guarantees have not
been met and that is why Russia didn't
renew this agreement that expired in
July now what are those agreements what
are those guarantees Russia is looking
for they include the return of Russia's
agricultural Bank to the Swift payment
system now although Russia's own grain
and fertilizers are not sanctioned by
Western countries there's a lot of other
things around these Goods that are under
sanctions including insurance companies
Logistics and equipment that prevents
Russia from selling its own grain to the
International Community that is one of
the main things Vladimir Putin is
looking to get guarantees on that they
will still be able to sell Russia's
grain to the world markets and of course
they also want to know that Western
businesses are not going to benefit from
this deal so president erdogan certainly
going to have a tall task ahead of him
and we understand the two men will meet
for at least a few hours whether or not
president erdogan will be able to
convince the Russian president to return
to this deal we'll have to wait and see
indeed we'll come back to you once we
get more news on what comes out of that
meeting Dr Jabari there for us in salt
Chi well back in key present Vladimir
zielinski has sacked his wartime defense
minister it's the biggest shake-up of
the Ukrainian defense establishment
since the Russian invasion last year
zelenski has nominated the head of the
country's main privatization front
who needs the approval of parliament
before he can replace Alexi aresnikov
the defense minister helped secure
billions of dollars in military aid for
the war effort during those past two
years and he's denied allegations of
corruption within his ministry
I've decided to replace the minister of
defense for Ukraine Alexi reznikov has
been through more than 550 days of
full-scale War I believe the ministry
needs new approaches and other formats
of interaction with both the military
and society as a whole
let's go back to Robert bride who's in
key force of course I mean what sort of
reverberations are now sort of being
felt after the announcement of uh what
zielinski has described as a new defense
minister
yeah I mean this was widely anticipated
there's been speculation about
resnikov's future for many months now
here in Ukraine but still uh it has come
as a big shake-up he was very much the
public face of uh Ukraine's military a
fluent uh polish and English speaker was
often uh he has very good relations with
the uh NATO backers of Ukraine was there
taking delivery and at the controls of
leopard tanks and so on so it has been a
big Shaker but uh zielinski saying that
you know he has been uh in his job since
the very start of this war it is time
for new approaches uh Resnick off has
now handed in his uh resignation but
there is some speculation that actually
he had been wanting a to find a
departure from this very high tension
high stress job that he's been in since
beginning of this war and of course it
does come as Ukraine is embarked on this
anti-corruption drive to make it more
appealing more acceptable to EU and to
Nato and there have been a series of
ongoing scandals within the ministry of
Defense things like conscription also
the some procurement contracts now none
of this is linked directly with resnikov
but he has it has been on his watch he
has been at the helm while these things
have been uh taking place so it does
seem as though uh both himself and the
ministry of defense and the zelensky
government have used this as an
opportunity it seems to part ways
Robert brought for us there in key
thanks for the update Rob